okay well we're looking at incremental
language development and big topic is
combinators 2020 is the centenary of the
invention of combinators and let's see
well let's talk about what we can do
with combinators raman do you want to UM
yes I mean this is a quick overview over
what kind of animals we need if you want
to support combinators I mean it's
really simple because there's a single
operation the binary Combinator
application which and then there are
these constants these Combinator's S&K
and some others that are useful if you
want to convert lambda expressions into
Combinator's and so to really support it
we need we need a symbol for the
operator and we need a notation so we
need an operator character here here I
use the left key because it has the
correct Association so it should pass
just like the left key but obviously
lefty is no good in this in this context
so the main issue is its function
application with different associativity
than normal function application is that
correct well I mean it's just customary
to write it left associative so that you
don't need all these parentheses but
it's always finally and there's no
distinction between functions and
arguments so everything can be applied
to everything so let me just understand
what you mean by that
so I mean for us if we write F of G of X
it's that yes okay
what is the corresponding thing for
combinations if I write s of K or
whatever well here you would write as
applied to parentheses
I mean you when somebody writes SS k / n
sk SS or something like that
yes what do they mean the non
parentheses always scoped with the list
okay so in particular that means what
does that mean
so if I type if if I say F G H what does
that mean that means F applied to G and
that applied to H okay okay so it's like
it's a it's an infix form of whereas
otherwise a match fix function
application thing that's a bad way to
say it I mean it's a what it is is it's
a um so if I look at F at star G the
whole thing that whole thing well
actually let me do another one at star h
the whole thing of x that's still the
wrong way around
yes it's not function composition its
application I think this is a bit like
having our construct but without letting
it evaluate and what sense without
looking at evaluate I mean in the sense
that if we have right it will convert
into f of X so if we just let this thing
be there construct f of X
it would be a bit of I don't think
you're right about this I mean I think
this is a ok this is a taking Korean
seriously story it seems to me I mean
every there's no notion of multiple
arguments right but I think in romance
from a reason he doesn't want to go all
the way to F of G it will stay us till
that true Roman
I mean Combinator's when you take an
expression a lambda expression convert
it in combinatory fool it's always in a
form that doesn't trigger any valuations
right so like K X K X would be an
example because but only when you apply
the why would it actually trigger
something and s if it has less than
three arguments then it doesn't do
anything and unfortunately many
Combinator expressions have no fixed
point yes I mean that that's one of the
main problems so we cannot simply have
global rules for the three cases that
are listed here on the left
because in all about trivial cases these
these would lead to infinite recursion
so if we want to actually work with
combinators we also need a way to
control the order of evaluation we'll
just back to the order evaluation I mean
M I mean because sometimes I mean if you
have a big combinatory term then there
are two natural ways of of trying to
reduce is one is to go the depth first
so you go which is called leftmost
innermost and the other one is to work
on the outer most reducible terms which
may have the side effect at some of the
inner ones which don't have a fixed
point are never used and just go away so
it's sometimes a way to to blow it
there's a picture
here's a picture these are combination
expressions being evaluated
from which which although do you use
here doesn't matter these cases no no
applied in Mathematica slash dot order
[Music]
yes its defined you know strangeness has
all come up in the physics project in a
big way um this whole question of order
evaluation and arguably we should have a
more global solution to that whole
question because in the case of replace
okay if I say you know look that the
sequence replace well actually the new
function subset replace has assist you
in a big way right because if I say
subset replace
oh great why isn't that working I should
be working that's a problem Devon can
you um flag that because that should be
yes yes I'll stretch out it something
loading problem for some characters yeah
yeah let's stretch well anyway um but
you understand that that's going to be
affected by the order yes I mean we the
general case I mean it's not so much the
old about the weather you go inside
first or you go work on the whole
expression before you work on the parts
that's one of the issues yes this is a
different issue I mean this is the this
is a different thing from this is yeah I
mean you're talking about funk
valuation this is talking about sequence
replacement which is related but not
quite the same okay you do know that an
SMP I had this function this thing that
controlled the different leftmost
innermost etc etcetera etcetera function
evaluation things it's like this is this
is a story like the Association story
which I had a mechanism that was like
associations in SMP and it didn't work
out well and so for 25 years I avoided
those so now similarly I had a mechanism
for controlling evaluation that didn't
work out well and so we still have such
mechanism what's that so is there
something that we should should now
reconsider and probably I mean I you
know I can show you what it did in SMP
you want sure we look um let me see if I
can find it um I mean I don't know what
systems have have that kind of control
do you know any way any place where that
that kind of control exists I mean most
systems like you know we have a very
definite evaluation order and
see him
you
you
you
um this was a thing
oh god this was such a freaking disaster
this was the analog yeah this was the
Association related to the association
disaster
um an NP is the analog of sequence
has the same exact disasters as our
sequences
you
I have a problem secure name and null
projection okay where is the evaluation
semantics patterns
you
that was a bad idea that was a kill
function play oh that was an even worse
idea that was that was module variables
I liked today yes yes that's but the
name already tells you the creature is
is you know um is um
um by the way somebody should answer the
question on the live stream where do I
send a new feature request for the live
stream for tomorrow I don't know the
answer to that but somebody should give
an answer I think it works through the
pre-release system but um Devon maybe
you know the answer and can give one I
do not know the answer ok well let's
let's get from that person let's get
some contact information and we'll I'll
make sure that they they can send it to
to this live stream now and we'll make
sure it gets passed to the right people
this is cool we don't have a procedure
for this yet
um where is this mechanism oh gosh this
was another disaster you know we should
look through here for all the disasters
this was the syntax modification thing
that I've referred to a bunch of times
yeah it's macros yeah we did and we get
them up same reason that this didn't
work the fundamental operations ok
automatic simplification that seems
relevant um
okay here we go
okay this is the whole story each filter
argument is simplified into unless the
value K of any corresponding simple
property carried by the projector
otherwise the head is zero this used
zero for boolean false future peril my
gosh okay that's an amusing thing to
have written in 1980 future parallel
processing implementations may not
respect this ordering we still don't
have that even now 40 years later um
okay until an in project is not carrying
the property rec have appeared
recursively at most k times
you
okay so do you understand what this is
saying so we in involvement which I mean
the semantics the evaluation order is is
always arguments before the whole
function that is correctly and so this
is a way to to turn this around yes that
is correct yes so maybe there's an
example here um we didn't yet have a
notebook idea of in dispersing
you
completely obscure oh here we go here we
go anvil further projections from SEM
projector recursion a sub projector
carries the rect property it may appear
recursively at most K times in the
simplification blah blah blah
you
fact that 40 years later we still don't
understand this as a super bad sign
oh that's interesting the SMP properties
of projectors such as multi x and plus
have value one some simplifications of
their projections are valid regardless
of the state of simplification of their
filters which is saying basically that
thing - thing is always equal to zero
whether or not thing has been evaluated
in other words if the hold of thing if
those are two identical holds assuming
no side effects it's going to assume
that those are actually identical and
can be subtracted to zero and so this
would be an example of outermost
simplification so exactly that even if
thing would explode you would just say
exactly yes right that exact aynd of
thing we need for Combinator's right
right so the classic example here was
doing okay so look his his his factorial
right so um this is an unterminated
factorial right so that G of 10
evaluates to zero whereas in what we
would get if we did the same thing here
right um and we typed in
ten kaboom recursion limits right but
the reason this doesn't yes reason this
doesn't do that is because here it it
this property it's trying the multiple
kit so it's somewhere in the sequence
right it multiplies by zero and then it
does outermost and then it's done okay
okay so this is what happens oh this is
this is tracing multiplication here
Arastoo CEO times G yes right
yes that seems like you like a useful
thing to have oh my god
forty years later okay let's have a
little talk about this whether we can
actually do something with this um okay
so in a modern terms that is and it's a
version of hold
what is it it's a version of hold way
you're trying you're doing a trial
evaluation of F without evaluating
what's inside
you
so for us um
you
yeah Bob on our live stream is saying
it's like a game of chess you try
simplifying in all possible ways until
you find a winning some provocation
actually let's think about that comment
in the light of 40 years worth of
additional information like they're
improving for example
I mean this it's just like trying trying
several strategies and see whether one
of them gives you know but this is a
different thing because because it is
correct that the issue is it's like
given a set of rip of rewrite rules does
there exist a sequence of rewrite rules
that gets too
that doesn't loop forever basically that
terminates
right now the problem is that in many
cases when there are infinite reductions
then the finite ones are not unique so
you may have more than one that
terminates two different results well
okay so let's think about that so in the
case of um
you
if the thing is confluent that will well
then the game is over everyone
terminates then there's a unique unique
result yes
in the case of confluence yes right but
in the case of confluence where not
everything terminates what's what
happens then
I'm no long it's a long time ago since I
worked on this so the question is under
which in which conditions do you still
have unique finite terms even if some
some chains are infinite right that I
don't know
you know bizarrely this has come up this
comes up a version of that question
comes up in the physics project um I
mean it is inherent to many kinds of
simplifications into I think it's no
surprise that it comes up in such
systems yeah and as I mean the way I
understood what you're doing is you have
big system and you go in and different
places and make make changes to
different parts and so this is very
relevant this question of termination
and uniqueness yes but the issue here
okay so so the question is
if okay the one result would be that
okay can you find a finite art so that
this is also Rob for replace repeated
right replace repeated has a very dumb
strategy right now for trying to get to
a fixed point
right I mean the question is can you get
to a fixed point and is there a unique
fixed point and do you care if there's a
unique fixed point or do you just want
some fixed point
right so I mean okay so in the case of
okay so you know for example okay so we
have replaced repeated what other
operations I mean in principle also
mainstream evaluation is another example
of something which you know evaluation
and also find equational proof
I claim question mark and the big issue
is does there exist a path that
terminates right and now let and if
there is is there one strategy that will
find it
well I remember results when I worked on
SMP 40 years ago there is there was a
claim in the recursive function
literature at that time about some kind
of outermost strategy guaranteeing to
work if it was ever going to work if
anything was going to work it's
conscious so I I deeply remember
something like that too so it's clearly
that outermost which we do not use which
is more likely to find look outermost is
basically lazy yes all right is there a
way to support this before we place
repeated and evaluation that doesn't
cause the headaches 40 years ago well
look the number one headache forty years
ago as nobody understood how what nobody
understood this at all
okay I mean in you know this was this
was just utterly obscure um
we just saved this in my place
um
[Music]
and then I want to loop back to
combinators and what will be useful for
them but I think we are actually on to a
more general issue of evaluation here so
okay so the question is let's take the
replace repeated example okay so what
let's let's have a real example I think
I had one recently that was just not
very clear whether there was a
termination a path determination um well
let's say you're doing the 3x plus one
problem as a replace repeated I assume
you can do that I mean if I write
something which says if even Q
well I could do actually a fixpoint is
another much more obvious thing yes the
three X plus one problem doesn't suffer
form no it doesn't suffer from these
these kinds of it's just that you don't
know whether it terminates okay but so
let's take fixed point as an example um
or is that an easier one as well because
it's just going F of F of F of F of F
think that may be easier because it
doesn't have multiple functions involved
yes I mean you're not you do not start
with some big term that may explode but
you build it up from the inside so I
think it's more it's more harmless right
but replace repeated could could go what
wrong because replace repeated I could
be doing I mean I literally wrote
something let me let me show you
something I just wrote recently for some
real purpose
okay here we go
so what this is is an attempt to build a
Kaylie graph from relations
okay so let's let's run it I can see
what it's doing so relations as in goog
Theo e for example yes but not a celli
group theory but so this is a free group
this is the Kelly graph for free group
okay so now I add the relation a B goes
to B a okay and then this closes its
arms up and so this was an attempt
that's an actual group and that was
maybe that's a cyclic group I think um
can recognize these things um yes seems
to have to generate a supporter 406 so
this was an attempt to do the quaternion
group okay so I have a function here
reduce word okay so that's doing a
string replace list it's attempting to
do a fixed point to reduce a word but we
know that I mean this this this is the
word problem for sort of semi semi
groups or in one special case is the
word problem for groups which we know is
undecidable so this is a quintessential
example something that might not
terminate and it depends on the order in
which you do these replacements if I'm
making sense right you can this is
trying to generate all possible
replacements I think and
you
yeah I mean this is a typical theorem
proving type thing generating all
possible replacements and trying to find
whether any of them you know yes I mean
that that's one thing the co movers they
try to date they control the order of
evaluations to avoid exactly on she said
exactly exactly I mean that's the and by
the way a comment from Bob on our live
stream could neuron that's guess the
next best simplification yes the answer
is yes that's an interesting thing that
we've been experimenting with in
strategies but they're improving and so
on and actually we probably should do
more with simplify on that I think we've
done some little stuff with that but
there's probably more that could be done
there um ah anyway okay um all right
let's come back to this from it so we
would need something like in replace
repeated and also in the evaluator that
controlled but I mean main main main
would be outermost and innermost right
those are the two most important ones
okay well let's think about what that
would look like so replace repeated see
this we could parameters these by taking
romance expressions with left T and
deciding in which order we replace each
left T by construct so if you go to the
left notebook yeah and and take that
expression with lefties and replace just
do replace of left T goes to construct
and here yes
right so we get these different things
and if a B and C had dumb values then
they would evaluate yeah I think the
question is in which order these
replacements or the sub values by the
way notice yes exactly right I see so
the question here is does it try to
evaluate the unn
resolved I mean the thing which is still
so you're saying it's a function
application but it hasn't yet been
turned into a genuine function
application yes I mean the the input
you're using here is just to illustrate
the associativity properties of left T
so the first and second term actually
actually the same you see because I the
input I used to I saw that is
parenthesized which which just to show
that the parentheses on the left are not
necessary but on the right there but I
think the advantage of Romans notation
is that if even if a and B and C have
non values they will not fire if we try
to use this notation we would have to be
holding everything continuously unless
of course we we would if you were to
implement global rules for S&K then of
course we would run into the same
problem that we couldn't control how it
evaluates and so my proposal is
essentially to not have any global rules
for SNK but just have to evaluate or
something and then have have functions
for say apply evaluate outermost apply
evaluate innermost now of course if
you're going to do that for general
replacement then we should do this use
the same same machinery for both cases
well I mean one way to do that would be
to say you're not doing actual function
application if you want
in other words imagine that there was a
version so normally we have f of X right
but imagine that we had F you know left
T of X is function application it just
is function application that never
it only uses own values this is
essentially this is what Combinator's
Combinator's do right Oh about this
symbolic application operation does I
mean it just sits there and and waits
for rules to be applied and the rules
would not be globally defined so
essentially this is a symbolic
I mean it's otherwise okay so what's the
analogy between this and inactive heads
you
I mean it would behave the same way but
adjust that using square brackets in
Combinator so just makes terms
unreadable no I understand that I I
understand let's not worry about the
syntax for a second there I'm trying to
understand the semantics of evaluation
here and what you're saying is if the
Combinator's were fundamentally inactive
then what you're describing is an
activation strategy right in other words
if I had something which was you know
inactive let's call them well let's say
inactive
of F of inactive am I about to get this
the wrong way around I think I agree
with this idea that this is what's
happening there in which order we
inactivate things OD and activate
activate sorry yes which are they we
activate
oh wow look at that why didn't those
turn into why didn't they typeset
exactly it's damnit heads I see they
could they could typeset but okay so
then then the idea is you've got a whole
nest of inactive things
and you try to have a strategy for
activating and we could even imagine
using the theorem prover
given that we know these combinator
reductions right we could imagine using
the theorem prover so
I think our existing theorem provers
should work for this case shouldn't it
I think so I think Shawn yeah I think
that's just one of the I mean it's just
one of the things that so I mean okay so
a very minor thing we should do is get
combinatory logic into the theorem
prover as an axiomatic system so that's
a good question if we look at axiomatic
theory right
you know if we say something like I
don't know the Shaffer axioms or
something um so here we do have
essentially this idea that is we have a
well in these cases these are more
algebraic and so they tend to have dot
operations not function application but
combinatorial logic is basically
something where I mean we could as well
use dot except for certain issues of
associativity right yes I mean the
Combinator logic has just that that
single that single Combinator
application operation okay so the first
most elementary thing is get the
Combinator axioms in to get the original
Sean Frankel Combinator axioms into
axiomatic theory because then the
theorem prover
that's an interesting idea the theorem
provers should be able to give us well
what will it give us it will tell us
does the theorem prover have the
capability to find a reduction it knows
given is this equal to this it could do
that do you think there's a way of using
the predicate logic theorem prover to
determine whether the thing is
terminating what is that what kind of a
logic question is termination this body
undecidable unfortunately but it sounds
like something that somebody nearly a
hundred years ago write more than 40 go
ahead and I'm thinking that what we can
encode in the prover is a set of
relations yes it's some sort of
particular strategy not so much the
general evaluation because what could be
an action for for evaluation well one of
these right I mean this is what we would
encode it's just that is it's just
axioms just like these ones it's that
yes XYZ is equal to this right so it's a
particular case not not the general case
you need to specify what your
combinators are yeah you need to have
Combinator symbols yep right it is a
specific comment or logic okay so now
the question would be
okay so for example let's I mean okay
let me just think for a second so so
then the idea would be that's one thing
is to get the pure I mean this is the
difference in equations and evaluation
right in other words the statement you
know X double equals seven or something
is a different statement from x equals
seven
that this is a bunch of relations I mean
so we can treat as a you know k of x and
y as reducing 2x or we can treat it as
being equivalent to X if you see what I
mean
yes Navi combinators we clearly need
reduction because we don't want to go
the other way
well maybe I mean I guess so
I guess it's a one-way so I guess the
difference is that it is like they're
improving but it is it's like these
things I've called multi way systems
which is like one-way equations so it's
a semi semi group but in general there
are proofs in which we will need to
expand X to K X Y that's immediately
split so it's not true I think so I
don't think it's always true that we
need to reduce sometimes we need to
expand temporarily and then reduce if
we're trying to proof exactly yeah and I
think M it may also be the case that
even in a reduction even in something we
think is a combinator reduction that the
efficient way to do the reductionist
through a proof that there exists a way
of getting there by going K always
reduces out but it is more efficient to
allow it to go the other way potentially
so I think with approval we cannot ask
what's the final reduction it's more
like is these reducible to D sort of
thing and then it would try to find a
path indeed indeed but I mean so the
question is the the kind of the search
of what is the reduction in other words
this is you know what we're trying to do
is Combinator simplify I mean that's the
ultimate function that we want we're not
going to have um you know Combinator
it's more like simplify it's not like
evaluate I claim because
evaluate in our normal down value sense
of evaluation we would get rid of all
the Kaizen assets we would reduce them
out but that's not going to be possible
here right all we can do is say what's
the simplest Combinator expression
equivalent to this which potentially
could be a combination expression that
doesn't terminate
so culminated simplify could go you know
you feed it a nonterminating expression
and it returns a simpler nonterminating
ones don't get simple but what do you
mean I mean you can cut certainly how
usually explode well I don't think
that's the case I think there are ones
here so I think I have examples so look
at these look at these things okay so
these are so here's an example of one
where it gets up to 5,000 and then it
cycles okay you might think that you
enter one of these large ones and should
be able to find the original one which
is boy oh boy oh boy so that is not
Combinator reduction in the sense of
that is that's exactly right I mean
that's a that's a thing where so I mean
look at what's happening in these cases
what's happening in these cases it's
really kind of horrifying is the cyclic
behavior now remember this is a
particular evaluation rule
see what I'm saying so
truely's in a most right mm let's figure
that out okay it evaluates all the parts
you
okay this was the rules
you
back is that
oh that's that's compilation of a lambda
expression and that's church numerals
okay so what we've got there um okay so
those are the Combinator rules and now
let's take let's do we could do an
actual Combinator reduction for plus
okay so let's take that's that there's
the increment operation okay so what we
should get there's the zero
okay so increment of zero right
is that okay so the claim would be
actually okay let's do the extreme case
let's do it times let's do let's do
increment of increment of zero okay so
that should be the church numeral for
two and let's do if I'm not mistaken the
times of and it's curried right so it
will be the times of the increment of
the increment is that right should be
okay so let's see what that produces -
okay so now we've got C rules here and
now in principle what we say is well
let's do a
I mean here it wouldn't matter right
because it terminates so well let's find
that out okay so slash slash dot C rules
it's the same freakin thing how can that
be well let's find out what oh look look
look look look
nest increment zero four times
you
that's different
you
okay
you
Oh
[Laughter]
oh my gosh that nest of SK comma n can
be converted the church numeral for n by
applying this thing here
Oh
okay well I don't understand why that's
different and I understand why that
didn't produce and it may be something
to do with the way Slashdot operates
let's see what the increment go ahead
perhaps you need to apply see ruzek as
one to the nest result
something's wrong here
power
I just didn't know that you could get
some okay hold on I was going to integer
n no I think the problem is that these
numbers numbers are still functional
functional operators so you have to
apply it to something oh yes yes yes yes
you're right I guess you're right
number n the number n is n fold
application so you have to apply it to
two arguments to an F to an X and then
you should get for f supply to X okay so
let's try percent 270 which is increment
increment 0 right so you claim that
applied to an F and G you think okay so
now this brilliant
okay so then this here after
multiplication right applying that to
why do we need to apply plus F and G why
isn't it just 2f well the result of
applying to F represents an FIR and fold
I CICS an application application of F
and proceed you have to apply to an
argument okay brilliant brilliant okay
so this thing here yeah that's what all
that prattling about about nest was
about okay so this is an example where
it terminates right okay so now
elsewhere i discuss
let's see
another one of those terrific pages of
um code that's a universal I mean
there's no way to talk to typeset these
nested things well I mean we don't know
because they haven't really been done
for years so we don't actually know it
could very well be um okay where do I
have this stuff about dominators hold on
that's presumably using your left T this
would look nicer was yes okay there's
the Combinator thing Combinator
properties okay here we go okay
at size 7 all but two of the 16,000
possible combination expressions evolved
to fixed points
you
okay so here's an example of a
combination expression that doesn't okay
so now if we go nest list slash dot c--
rules okay this is our first example of
a non terminating rule application in
this way of doing it okay in a very very
with very obscure output right so if we
go here I only know what we compute here
we could compute leaf count here
so if we say leaf count
Oh even that sequence is just something
totally bizarre okay I'm now curious if
we go a bit further here let's go to 20
that may be living to dangerously let's
just see what happens to the leaf count
there
okay see in modern times whether we can
tell what this is not a good sign if it
doesn't come back immediately it's
usually not gonna come back okay but so
this is a good example this is an
example of a nonterminating Combinator
expression right under combinatory
reductions supposedly okay I don't think
it's finding this finding it which is
even bizarre in its own right into
expressions that grow like two to the
- well let's find out whether they are
linear recurrences
nope they're not ok well that's totally
weird
okay so let's ask whether there is a
strategy for evaluation which would
cause this to I mean maybe this simply
doesn't terminate right
yes I mean they I mean it's it's
possible that that it doesn't matter
which order you apply to but the
termination might be it could be if I
take one of the other terms here let's
say I take the one from here then it is
the case that there is a Combinator
simplification because that guy um oh by
the way I want to see what this looks
like if we if we implement it with lefty
so that guy is in fact equivalent to
this simple accommodator expression
right okay let's see what this would
look like if we use lefty for it how
would we do that it's a pattern a blank
bracket B blank goes to lefty our own
lefty a b-list e.t me okay
all right now I take this expression
here and what do i do I just say slash
slash dot that yeah I think so
you
you
certainly got no lack of parentheses
you
I mean that's moderately ugly I don't
know which is more obscure to read than
which that one has the advantage that
you know what function is applied to
what function I mean this is just you
know I'm by the way you know combinators
in real life my examples here are some
of the better examples of Combinator's
in real life I don't think you find you
know people haven't done computerized
Combinator stuff this much um
so I'm not buying this I mean for very
small things I can see that this might
work but for something from the wild
this doesn't seem to be a big advantage
I find the lefty form much easier to do
weak this form well okay fine I don't
find either form very easy to read let's
let's take let's see what this would
look like just for fun oh gosh it's all
in the head right it was a lifting let's
try that definitely better
I mean that's better that's a real tree
yes and we see the repetition these
longer leaves that's a good point how do
we turn this into an ordinary tree we
don't have that yet right expression
tree is the thing that would turn it
into a tree I guess it would be
equivalent to the original expression so
send him lefty by constructing him
what do you mean I mean if we apply to
this to hunt output 287 there will be
four lefty goes to construct we should
recover your original expression oh sure
yeah so that will be the expression
equivalent to this one
right but that that's simply saying that
this is
the symbolic version of function
application right right which is
otherwise known we could write this as
okay so again repeating that I mean what
we have is is construct of a B does that
we could imagine a symbolic construct a
B which is equivalent to left T right or
an inactive construct or delayed
constructor
right but what's the difference in
inactive construct and just inactive of
the head
because the the symbols here I see that
because inactive is the only thing
inactive does is to prevent down value
evaluation right you could say inactive
of construct exactly that's what I was
thinking because this is more symmetric
so in this language I think everything
is a function both a and B s is a
function well for construct Asia
function B is an argument yes so what's
your point that treating a and B in a
symmetric way rather than in activating
a applied to B it's more natural okay
all right but so what are you gonna do
with all this stuff so I mean we've got
um so I think the main point here is
that we see the difference between the
purely typesetting how do you input
stuff versus what it actually
semantically means okay let's let's zoom
out for a second we got two issues here
one is the pretty interesting question
of whether we support a different form
of evaluation semantics particularly
relevant for replace repeated
and I mean the other is specifically
about Combinator's and the question is
what on earth are people going to do
with Combinator's so my proposal was
essentially to provide the notational
support for doing whatever people want
to do with it so we need that Combinator
apply or inactive constructor and then
we need the operator symbol a nice
escape form and a nice output form that
does what that looks the way it's
supposed to look as a Combinator
expression then we need that T operator
that turns lambda expressions into
combinators and the reverse which turns
it back into lambda expressions and then
but in general wait a minute there are
specific
lambda expressions that we can compile
into SK Combinator's but the general
lambda expression that involves you know
square roots and things we can't compile
it into SK combinators in any scene we
would the square would would be a
constant but our list operations also
there's no way right I mean the list
operations are just way more complicated
than Combinator things no I mean lists
you would probably tweet lists as as as
projections right I mean a list is a
tuple and the tuple can be represented
as a as a common aid how well I mean
that the tuple would have two property
that when you apply and probably church
normals to it right that it would give
you the correct component that's one way
of doing it
that's extremely obscure I don't know
whether there is there are better ways
but I mean there's clearly a pair
construction coming yeah right turn with
F and even F F and T falls into the
conditioner is particularly nice because
the conditional just applies that a
tooth value is a condition I'll write
the tools well you apply to two
arguments X and y gives you X if it's
true and Y if it's false so the if
expression is to take really nice and
communities okay look the basic you know
sociological fact about Combinator's is
next year they will have been around for
a hundred years they haven't exactly
taken off you know yet as a practical
thing to use
partly because I mean it took probably
40 years we built how long did it take
for people to understand that
Combinator's were equivalent to lambda
calculus it took until Curie and so on
right yeah
it was what end of the 1930s or
something well whatever but I mean okay
but then okay
I mean I think they'd ever more or less
developed together until somebody found
out that the Y Combinator
destroyed everything and what sense well
because because everything has a fixed
point and so language where to and falls
at fixed points is it's not very useful
what do you mean all right because it's
always always gives you contradictions I
mean I don't this is that this is a
piece of common Eider law that i do not
know so what you're saying is I mean the
Y Combinator gets to a fixed point y
combinator what service I mean every for
every expression X Y of X is a fixed
point of X and so everything has a fixed
point so now what is the fixed point of
negation well but I don't understand for
example that combination expression I
just gave with the esses what will be
its fixed point well in most cases most
cases you cannot actually compute them
but the point is that you there is a
reduction that when it uses Y of X to X
of Y of X I understand by the
definition of why
Isaac is some super fish SS encasing but
there is one with action but none of it
there's an equation involving Y that Y
asserts is true but in the case of the
the expression that I just gave that
doesn't terminate
what does that mean for I mean that's
then an equation that is one of our
outermost true only in outer most form
equations I think right that is there
exists a fixed point but that fixed
point
you know it blows up before your very
eyes so to speak as you apply the Y
Combinator depending on which order you
apply the thing in it's either if you do
the innermost application that s
expression is going to just blow up I
mean if you look at the derivation of Y
I mean de that basically gives you a
sequence of steps that goes from Y of X
to X of Y of X right assuming that X
doesn't blow up yeah assuming you yes
you never touch it right so slight so
that's an outermost yes that's an
outermost reduction right so so the idea
would be okay so here is a general
concept for function you know in other
words see what you can do with the
outermost functions
before you ever go down inside yes I
think what you have it you know useful
concept for before coming for working
with combinators and probably also in
other cases let's think about other
cases when would that be useful so the
/c in our evaluation semantics there are
two things going on there is a function
being reapplied
and there is continuing to walk through
the expression
different types of things right so in
other words
in the case of map
no that's a good example so you know
when you do let's say we do
yes but I mean in general if we say F of
G of X comma H of X there's both the
evaluation of G which could blow up
right but then yo yo yo this is that
this is the example right so so take a
look at this right so what do we do here
the what we do right now is we try and
evaluate G of X
okay we try and get a fixed point of G
of X um and we we do that in a most in
the most and most we try and get to it
let's say we did that more outermost e
we wouldn't finish doing G of X we tried
U of X we'd say oh that's hopeless let's
stop let's do H of X instead okay now it
could be the case that F is a function
defined so that if its second argument
is zero the whole thing is zero so after
we've tried G of X for a while we try H
of x OE h of X goes to 0 therefore the f
is zero and we're done we don't care
what G is yes but but remember there are
two different things here so the other
thing that could happen is G of X could
turn in something else
in other words there's a chain below G
of X and then there's a but that chain
the same thing could recursively happen
in the chain below G of X that it could
have something else where there's a
branch where you do to the left one or
the right one okay let's look at what I
did 40 years ago I think I had a scheme
for dealing with this I think that's
what this K thing is all about
carries the property rack
at most k times
in the simplification of a filter and
this thing before the simplification of
the projection is performed okay that's
exactly this so that's saying
that's saying this thing G in the
evaluation chain down here can appear at
most K times before you stop and you try
and and you keep going and then you try
and do the F
you
so I'm saying so so the innermost
strategy would be this property of G is
infinite is infinity so you go you know
you just keep going down that that path
right the outermost strategy would be
its zero don't even try to do G but
ultimately without a most you won't get
anywhere because in the end to resolve F
the yes example would be 1 minus 1 times
something you need to look at the
argument to see that it is zero right
times 1 minus 1 X right you you won't be
able to resolve that without doing and
that's why so I think the strategy that
I had there the dick course but the
strategy would be
I think it had some we're making
progress um let's think about this for a
second so again let's look at this in
the case of replacement what is the M
our analog of this for replacement this
is for evaluation which I think will be
very very tricky to deal with I mean in
other words we could okay let's let's
imagine that we had a rapper called um
you know tentative evaluation let's say
okay
and that what happens is that tentative
tries evaluating once one like having a
very small a recursion that's true so
what would happen if we do okay let's
try that let's try that let's say block
dollar recursion limit equals four let's
define our factorial I think there is a
minimum value
you
at least 20 okay
Oh
you
why did it return that hole why didn't
it return the whole sequence
I think mrs. stander when they start
cashing limited always returns are
wholesome but look at this also during
evaluation of FAC of 8-1
okay let me I'm sorry I need to try a
smaller factorial here I need to try
factorial of ten that's freaking weird I
see it never went back up again it never
went back up again I found out that it
had a zero see what I'm saying right
yeah it's still in the most right right
I mean we need we need to catch this
hold and do something useful with that
if you want to implement the tentative
thing
but a way to think about this is I mean
this is one step evaluation is what we
have to do here right and
yes I mean we we personally meet when it
8 then it gives up but if you had some
other way of say do a couple of steps
and we turn whatever you have then that
CEO would surface right I mean if if how
would you define a step is it is it one
element on the stack
yeah one one application of let's see
what this looks like if I if I echo the
stack here I'm essentially what slash
dot would do right but hold on what what
is what is what is the stack how do I
get the stack what is it was the name
for the stack
stack yeah I think so this may be very
horrifying what happens here
you
you
no no that's not where I want to put it
I want to do is
I want to put it in the definition of
FAC here I want to put an echo
I want to say
Co stack semicolon that let's see just
how horrifying this ends up being okay
now let's try this
dah dah
how did that happen
you
you
let's try a smaller factorial here well
I see we have to go 20 times down
during evaluation of infinity
that's something very very funky because
that was a stack depth the thing was
that that's why we set a minimum rail
recursion limit because it twice it
tries to format the stack and that runs
into the same recursively meter right
exactly why it returns zero I'm not
completely sure um well okay in any case
but let's go back up here so could you
walk me through what the thing is for
replace all but replace repeated rather
what's the analog of this replace
repeated no what I meant was replace
single replacement that's one step right
it is yes yes and so we need a way to
say whether we go inside first exactly
so in double in and replace repeated
right this is what we need in replace
repeated okay let's look at this let's
clear fack and now let's say FAC of X
plane arrow x times back of X minus one
you
yes : her I think that's right Mohammed
my life stream is talking about quotes
now now that doesn't solve the problem
that's some um the that is a very naive
and simple hold as a much better version
of that problem but the problem with
hold the problem of quotes the problem
of holding is what holds the holder of
holding I mean it's it never it never
works
um it's just a band-aid okay so let's
let's look here so if I say replace
repeated well actually let's just try
the most naive thing here replace
repeated of FAC of five comma this I
think we'll run into an iteration limit
but I'm wrong how did that possibly work
okay I just do this
go ahead before it valid sorry before
because it evaluates before it goes to
the next step next replacement and so
the 0 times happens well that's nice but
of course that intermix is the control
evaluation of sectorial with the
uncontrolled evaluation of times they
actually do to get hold of both of these
so so instead of using it's just this oh
I'm I'm curious about something here so
this here right if I do replace repeated
a fib of of like 5 here but this I don't
think this will do what and I say
/ /
timing
oh there's no errand end condition egg
egg egg egg egg okay that's another
horrifying thing right because I would
be well let's put the end conditions in
as if as as some assignments I don't
think it's going to matter to what I
want to show
you
okay now let's try fill of 10
this is very interesting you saw I'm
seeing what's happening here
is that this is not in a most evaluation
would have complexity fight at the end
right this isn't doing in a most
evaluation so if I were to do does he
cool yes because it does plus before
right so how can we see that can we see
that in in um
how can we see that we could see that by
doing an echo somewhere here how could
we see that going on
I guess if we do you know we if we put
an echo in here
well at least we could echo n think of
we echo anything else that's going to go
crazy but it's an interesting question
but how do you see the intermediate
things that get applied integrase
repeated yes I understand help okay that
was not a good sign so let's actually do
something different here let's so these
and then let's reap them on the outside
okay I don't understand this that seems
to have an awful lot of values in it so
I'm saying let's find out how many
values that has um
it certainly doesn't seem to have 10000
values so that's a good sign
I'll figure mistake what I want so I
want part 2 2 1
right here let's do this let's do this
let's do this let's just compute um I
should forget the timing for a second
yeah there we go well this is also
telling us the evaluation order so this
is giving us so that thing there
okay that's the evaluation sequence in
some sense so I claim is probably going
to be quadratic and then this thing if I
do this for
[Music]
what happens if you use nest and single
replacement an iceless them you should
be able to see I always should be able
to sit and that I reckon
hard to know hmm hot to know it's got
220 let's see what it does hmm it's not
my favorite quadratic increase doesn't
look very quadratic to me
that is freaking weird because that's
not the golden ratio
the golden ratio but still exponential
all right there's something to
understand here but um but your point is
that if we did this with a nest
I don't know whether it's a
let's try it okay so let's say we have
an S list and this is just a hash slash
dot bat thing um actually we need to say
fix point list I see I see what's
happening is this what would happen is
if if what we put in there was a so
let's say fib of a ignore that and let's
just do this flip of ten for example
watch this okay so this is actually
quite interesting okay so there's the
answer
I'm simplification but not complete
right but look at this if what we did
was this
you
I've acted in that work
oh because the expand doesn't get done
at the right time this would work I
think
you
you
it's shorter but not much shorter what's
only expander around cold sink oh yeah
yeah yeah right
you are correct
okay but now this is yet a different
bizarre version of outermost evaluation
right
have a helper function
well I mean it is it does out the most
but it also does some parts
in a most like mean we took control of
the FIP but we did not take control of
the times at the plus right but if you
do nothing in them if you do nothing in
a most nothing's going to happen
but the things just gonna sit there
lazily yes so you are what started the
whole thing about this tentative or so
that you need some in the most steps in
between that seems very relevant right
but what this is saying is I mean
parameterizing look what this is
basically saying is in replace repeated
there - there are two things in replace
repeated um one the
intermediate function apply an
intermediate function between repeats
that's one possibility
right eg expand or something yes and
also for for tracing right
yeah just like echo also right um okay
the second thing is
yeah which part of the expression is the
slash dot applied to first right and
that's relevant in the case of F of G of
X H of X because we could apply that
slash dot you know is the is the slash
dot applied in a most I don't even know
do you know the answer for that if I do
a replace repeated let's say I say X
plank of Y blank X blank of well let's
just do X blank of Y blank goes to hello
and then I say F of G of X I got it the
wrong way around
you
but we still have some F so cheese
defined
I think this is more bizarre than you
think because I think if we do this um
what the heck is G defined
I think G was to find otherwise this is
just in comprehensible okay so that is
going in a most right in other words it
didn't well that's going in some bizarre
outermost way this the head I mean you
still have one left
whatever you do first
yes it matters because because in this
intermediate simplification thing if it
was F of hello evaluation good that
would still match the no no but I
understand that that would well in that
particular case it would still match the
rule but you could imagine that it would
no longer match the rule
now if you do X of my code on arrow X
then you should probably see what no it
doesn't matter you cannot have something
that matches they write it well right
but I mean look at this
you
right so that's the general that's the
general case of what can happen right
there's no guarantee that it will that
it will can you know but but the
question is what's the answer to most
right but the question is what should
this do what would you even want this I
mean in this particular case just going
to cycle forever
let me ask you another question I have
got to go in a moment here but but um
imagine this was being done concurrently
imagine there were multiple parallel
programs that were doing this
honestly
there are
only certain confluent rewriting systems
where the ants sir I mean in most cases
the answer would simply be undefined
you get a whole variety of different
answers unless this confluence
maybe an termination I'm not sure
Wow it's amazing that we've been able to
go 33 years without the stuff I mean
look I remember when when was it I think
it was actually this happened even with
SMP because SMP was and also of
languages is an infinite evaluation
system right and all these people who
said such a system is impossible
was a very common thing that I heard
when people knew that it was an
evaluation system they just said oh it's
impossible um I mean the the attributes
to hold the whole that baby would
certainly I mean able to also probably
be irrelevant here because they would
actually prevent D the inner most
evaluations
and still go away automatically so I
think we should also look at the hold
attributes how they play with this right
well I'm afraid we're going to we need
to wrap him we should we should meet
again about this is very interesting it
will be nice ok so I have a suspicion
here that if we can solve this decently
of parametrizing evaluation order that
this will be useful for a lot more than
just this that'll be useful for
um and I also have a feeling that it
will be relevant in defining
in effect locking for concurrent
processes
because I claimed this is a highly
related question I claim this in a most
outermost what gets evaluated when is
closely related to is the result ready
from a parallel pronoun from a
concurrent program do you believe that
would you think that's the
question of of is it ready yet and do I
want to like for example I could even
say I don't care what that program what
result that program gives because I'm
going to multiply it by zero
but the question of whether you try so
here's the issue the issue is in most
ways of doing concurrent programming you
have these various kinds of locks and
you say I'm not gonna go on and do any
more to my code until everything came
back from mum by the way talking
parallel programming did you see this I
have my 40 40 cause actually up and
running and I I computed something all
night on all 40 cause it took 11 hours
and actually Kemp came back with an
answer saying by email about the new
version of that dialog is now that yeah
I know I just I I don't want to use the
prototype build so okay um because I've
got other because if I'm running the
thing all night and I'm generating 7.5
gigabytes of output I would prefer for
thing didn't crash because it's a
prototype build moments before it return
a result um the
any case um do you get what I'm saying
that the point that I'm making is
normally when you think about concurrent
programming you have to say in order to
go on with the computation I need to
have yeah I need to block until
everything returns like you know
parallel table or something blocks until
all the table results are there parallel
try does not parallel try waits until
something works right
but actually what is the analogy here
between parallel try and you know this
feels like
versus parallel table peril try says
well I don't know there's quite an
analogy but my point is if we could
figure this thing out with them the bar
on this live stream is asking how do I
have forty cause if you look closely
you'll discover this is multiple
machines and that's using their setup as
in the parallel peril process
configuration dialog you can hook in
different remote machines I'm hoping to
have another twenty in a few days um
and I'm also going to actually be
running using I'm going to be running a
batch processing on on AWS
um which hopefully will work too anyway
but but this is the thing I'm describing
is a good idea
the do you get it does anybody else
who's here if nobody nobody else is
still that this the point is normally in
concurrent programming you think you
have to wait until everything like all
the arguments of the function have come
back so to speak but my point is in this
way of saying but there is an
intermediate certification step that may
mean that I've got enough arguments back
let's say I've got a boolean function
and I'm asking for you know majority or
something and this may already be
applicable in because the way parallel
submit and wait work is that the result
of parallel submit is a symbolic
representation of that that that
evaluation job and these jobs are
expressions and you could actually do
those kinds of expand or now of course
if you multiply by 0 then that kernel is
lost right because you destroy the
handle to that job that you are no
longer interested so it's not that easy
I see what what do you mean you destroy
the handle why do you destroy the handle
well I mean I you FCO times
result of this job and you simplify and
then you lose well we just enrolled I
understand it but you have to know that
that happened right you have to have a
have to you would have to we after
simplification you would have I do
garbage collection on on your parallel
jobs well so what you would do is you
would do the intermediate simplification
step then you would look at the result
and you would say okay now you know
which jobs are still being referenced
here yes and the and instead of 0 times
job equals C or you would say zero times
job equals kill job Co something like
that yeah effectively yes garbage
collection yes right but I mean the
thing I don't know is how general this
phenomenon of
you know um
you know how useful because you know one
of the reasons I didn't pursue this
apart from the utter nobody understood
it problem with SMP the other thing was
you know I had a lot of toys ampuls
where this was relevant but not a lot of
real ones actually Brian our live stream
is pointing out that you could try
speculative execution on the parallel
evaluation yeah I mean that's
effectively what this is about this is
this is this tentative thing is
effectively speculative execution
so a good observation
like what would happen if I did this and
so long as it's these functions are pure
there's no harm in doing that okay this
is an interesting topic we should
explore this further
I predict there's going to be some
really interesting possibilities here
and 40 years later let's see if we can
reduce out that paragraph um there
anything to something understand by the
way yeah i know i mean i i'm i'm just
i'm i don't think i mean actually that
you know there's a lot of training
materials that were written for us on
piece so i think come um i they probably
ignored this part it's probably they
thought that was just me being crazy
okay somebody asked by the way if SMP is
available unfortunately no for a long
time its source code was encrypted but
finally the encryption was and we forgot
the password
finally the encryption was broken by
somebody much younger than the than the
age of SMP a few years ago and I think
see I think I might Tim no I can't do it
I don't think I can I've gotta go to a
different meeting but let's just see
just for fun since it's so close to
holiday time let's just see um
I think that is going to give me what I
want here um
No um no oh well I thought I might be
able to I did have a way of running it
on this machine but it's running through
some kind of VAX emulator or something
um because it's because it's written in
C but um over the course of well 40
years it turns out it has enough library
dependency that it really doesn't work
without an emulator of the environment
um and um but it does run um and we
could try all these things um all right
we seem to have one more comment coming
from the livestream that's wait for that
oh yes I'm being given a reminder that
tomorrow we are having a session about
product suggestions and um bugs and so
on and we'll talk about things that
people bring up and what their status is
and for us it's really useful way to
learn about people's priorities and I
hope hopefully will tune in for that and
if you bring up outer most evaluation
we'll know you hear how we'll also know
it's not the highest priority it's been
hanging out there for 40 years so it's
probably not some not as urgent as other
things um all right thanks a lot
so will I look forward to continuing
this meeting I'm I'm really really
interested to try and I think as I say
this may sound unbelievably obscure but
I think there's something interesting to
be gotten from it um and also let's do
it in in in recognition of Moses Shawn
Finkel and the invention of combinators
unfortunate I don't know the date that
combinators were invented I tried to
track that down a while ago but the
paper was submitted in 1920 by well
actually Moses Shawn Franco was a
student of David Hilbert's and
unfortunately had some kind of
psychological meltdown of some
thought um and I believe the the the
paper was actually eventually submitted
by Paul Bernays of of other logic Fame
um but anyway I have to go sort out that
history if I'm gonna write something
about the history of Combinator's um
okay good stuff talk to y'all soon